now let's move on to rendering
performance your goal for rendering for
scrolling and animations particularly
should be smooth jank free rendering if
your app is jumping around as the user
scrolls or if an animation is
periodically freezing or running at less
than a fast consistent frame rate then
your users will be unhappy with the
experience on desktop we always tell you
the magic number is 16 milliseconds
that's a single frame when you're
running at 60 frames a second
which is the usual frame rate of the
monitor that's not always true and
actually it's not even that you need to
consistently hit 60 frames a second it's
far more important to have a consistent
frame rate than a high frame rate